you know is the youngest of nine the
last to come along sad at the little
table on the side of the the room always
had the battle to get my views across or
to be able to express it but I had
extraordinary role models my father who
was very ambitious for his children and
it was a great disappear
who was the safe haven devoted to her
faith and also the love of history my
older brothers who were great heroes of
mine and were inspiring figures all the
way through my life my brother had been
elected to the Congress and he asked me
whether I wanted a tour of Washington
and I welcomed the opportunity and he
brought me around to the House of
Representatives and brought me to the
United States Senate I brought me over
to the Supreme Court of the United
States pointed out the White House he
gave advice to me then which really has
stuck with me I was probably 12 years
old at the at the time and he said to
look you'll you'll visit the buildings
now you'll see these buildings there
b-but he said that the really importance
of this visit is that you take an
interest in what is happens inside these
buildings for the rest of your life and
I thought well that's a nice sort of
idea but you know when when are we going
to get hotdogs or something or other or
go to a baseball or a football game but
the resonance of that message stayed
with me with me all of my life it's the
way only wave really our democracy is
going to work as if people take the
interest take the time our history and
our tradition is filled with millions
who have made this country the great
country as it is all a my
great-grandparents arrived in East
Boston at the dock I can look out my
window
in the JFK building in Boston I could
see the dock that they arrived it I can
see the stairs which are called the
golden stairs that lead on now help him
to East Boston every one of them went up
to that not knowing what was going to
happen they were fortunate some were
fortunate and we were able to
participate in the democracy it's a
great gift when I first arrived in the
United States Senate it was primarily in
knocking down walls of discrimination we
still have a ways to go but we were
looking then after passing
medicare/medicaid our education at that
time
I have been faced both adversity witness
great success of the times of
particularly my brothers sort of
achievement but I I think this this is a
the the sort of the values of our
country of society of worth fighting for
and I see people who struggle and
struggle very hard to try and make a
difference for the nation which inspires
me that schoolteacher that the law
enforcement the legal defender that's
trying to that health care worker trying
to give health care trying to give
education trying to protect bring the
Constitution to people who didn't know
that they had constitutional rights and
liberties
one was religion which is very very
important particularly for my mother and
father but also for the members of our
family and has been incredibly important
in terms of my life particularly facing
some of the real challenging times that
I've had to face members of my family
that have been lost other kinds of
tragedies feeding the hungry and giving
to the those that are thirsty and
clothing the naked and visiting the
welcoming the stranger and visiting the
imprisoned these words can be simple
words but they can also be guiding words
and they've been guiding for me in the
United States Senate there's a very
still the court understanding and
awareness that America is just not a
land but it's a promise and it does seem
to me this particular year as we're
coming into the presidential year the
the energy and the liveliness and the
enthusiasm in particularly on our side
and the Democratic side with the
Democratic candidates is very alive and
very well and very involved and I mean
the polls reflect it but all you have to
do is see the turnouts of people that
are turning out and involved and engaged
I think the program's change in times
change but to values that really don't
change